good morning believe nation today's
messages always be learning I'm going to
share with you an inspiring clip from
Charlie Munger that I think you'll enjoy
the other great secret is that we're
good at lifelong learning
Warren is so much better in some ways in
his 70s and 80s and he was younger that
it's almost awesome if you keep learning
all the time you have a huge advantage
so what if I'm really interesting about
this clip is even got Charlie Munger
here's a guy who's in his 90s talking
about continual learning right he's over
90 years old and he's still interested
in learning and this is a really
important message for entrepreneurs
because in our businesses you have to
feel like you're always learning and
growing if you're not growing you're
slowly dying and a big problem for a lot
of entrepreneurs is at the startup phase
you're all excited right you've launched
this business you're all excited for the
next three six twelve months you're off
and running and and you're running on
fumes and you're you've got lots of
energy and then you hit a wall and often
that's because you're not growing
anymore
you're not learning anymore you know
you're not developing new skills and
talents you've learned everything you
needed to the startup phase you're not
seeing the results in your business and
so you start to slow down and that's a
really critical time if that's where you
are right now with your business it's a
really critical time that you continue
to invest in yourself that you continue
to learn and grow and as a person and
also within your business I've even
found that sometimes when I'm struggling
in my business I'll look to personal
things to learn and develop and grow I
might learn some new salsa moves I might
learn something on my rip stick and just
that feeling of learning something new
we energizes me that I can bring back to
what I'm doing in my business so if
that's you right now if you're feeling
like you're in a slump you're feeling
like nothing's going right you don't
have a lot of energy it's probably
because you're not learning anything new
in your life right now and so develop
that skill right develop that habit
continue to learn something learn for
your personal cell learn for something
that can help in your business
you'll find that it makes you happy a
person and makes you a much better
entrepreneur believe so my question the
day for you today is what are you
learning I'm curious to know what you're
learning right now leave it in the
comments below I want to join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe have an
amazing day and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of an
espresso